i completely understand why the patriots
did it
and the psychology of it i think is
fascinating
by waiting to make their move they ran
the risk that someone else was going to
sign him but also
they created a circumstance
where if
uh cam newton had no other suitors and
he had no other suitors he was going to
take whatever offer the patriots put out
there
seen a lot of criticism of the contract
comparisons to chase daniel chase daniel
making more than cam newton and jameis
winston combined this year okay fine but
the reality is
neither newton
nor winston had a ton of leverage when
the time came for them to sign their
contract nobody wanted winston to be a
starter people were leery about him
being a backup because he's used to
being a starter he wants to be a starter
chase daniel better fits into that
backup role who will accept his position
and not try to take over that was part
of the i think problem for getting james
winston a good backup contract and then
you throw in the fact that cam newton
just wasn't healthy and was a victim of
circumstance a victim of the panthers
not cutting him when they should have
back in february like they cut greg
olsen and the panthers thinking they can
get something in exchange for cam newton
so they held on to him longer than they
should have and then when they finally
cut him there's no fair opportunity for
him to go out and see what's on the
market to get a physical because of the
pandemic so he was stuck he was stuck
and it's unfortunate that it happened
but now he's making chicken salad he's
taking the deal that he can get so he
can get the opportunity to position
himself for next year see if he doesn't
do this deal now
he's going to be in a tough spot to have
the kind of season necessary to make him
an attractive free agent in 2021
he would have been waiting for someone
to get injured
and look you never know who's going to
get injured who's not going to get
injured you can't predict that what if
it's an injury to a quarterback on a
team you really want to play for or what
if you're not sure how long the injury
is what if it's not season ending but
maybe the guy's gonna be out eight weeks
do you go for eight weeks then you have
to worry about being benched for
the starter when he recovers and what if
a team who has an injury to a
quarterback just says next man up we got
a guy who's here who knows the system
this move gets cam newton to new england
to learn the system compete with jared
stidham at a time when student didn't
have an off-season program as the number
one guy i mean think about that we've
seen plenty of praise of jared stidham
from patriots players over the past
several months but there's never been a
moment in his time in the nfl where
jared stidham has been the guy in a
locker room full of his peers never been
the guy and now here comes cam newton
who is clearly the guy so it's going to
be easier for newton to compete it's
going to be easier for him to get the
starting job it was smart for him to do
it now i think the patriots knew exactly
what they were doing by waiting i think
they were interested in him all along on
their terms
and they knew that the best way to get
him on their terms was to wait and they
did and they were willing to assume the
risk that he would land somewhere else
and you know what because they never let
on that they wanted him nobody ever
would have said paul the patriots blew
that see that's the value of keeping
your mouth shut and that's what the
patriots do and this is one of the
reasons why they do it because if you do
come off as being too anxious number one
it drives up the price number two if you
don't get the guy you look like you've
lost
instead the patriots look like they've
won and they quite possibly have and cam
newton quite possibly has won as well
depending upon how things go this year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports